with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and common
sense upbeat and entertaining straight
talking and direct we may have to take
each other and here provoking hello and
welcome to the page now here on the
program we're lucky enough to have
several of Fitness finest journalists on
the panel hard-nosed hacks who can sniff
out a good story in a heartbeat and know
how to make it a front page splash such
talent should never go unnoticed which
is why Carol I have to commend you on
your scoop of this century
I wanted a latte that's right she was
left gasping in disbelief after a
barista refused to serve her an extra
hot coffee not one to ever take
something lying down now carol has used
her platform toward others of this
complete coffee snob early telling her
tale in the Daily Express and the Dorset
echo and going viral in the process well
Carl you might have put up though these
two out of business but at least you
express ode yes sir Carol yeah it's
stone cold but drinking but once in your
life don't complain and by the way he
wasn't it didn't work in the do the shop
but anyway coming up on the program
Majeed presses pulls on the TV licence
fee and who argues the press aren't to
blame for caroline flakes death I'm
taking aim at the lack of regulation in
football and June argues we need more
diversity in our music industry but
first its cappuccino cow I'm going to
let that pass okay this week's historic
shake-up of Britain's immigration system
is exactly what millions voted for in
the referendum it's about taking back
control of our borders choosing those
who come here on merit rather than
nationality and
picking skills worldwide from the
brightest of the best from January 2021
people who come here have to have a job
they have to speak English contribute to
the NHS and we can exclude those with
criminal records so yes it should be
welcomed but with caution if British
employers are to stop dependence on
cheap labour and they must the
government must held then the 800
thousand young people currently not in
work or education must be helped into
the workplace with top class training
and apprentice schemes and the
government must re-establish its
contract with the British labour force
with opportunities and incentives
Britain has a proud history of welcoming
people from all over the world now as an
independent self-governing country we
can choose who comes to live here with
an immigration policy that works in our
interests and not in the --use and if we
do this right there'll be no stopping us
[Music]
Carol I thought was quite interesting
with the reaction of the Labour Party
they all attacked the proposed ones even
though this is a reheating of Tony
Blair's own points policy but I think
what's it could come out of this
actually is a better workforce for
Britain because since 2004 when Tony
Blair opened the floodgates to Eastern
Europeans he was told at the time to
have in to have transitional
arrangements so there were limits on how
many came in that was the rule across
most of the rest of the European Union
so we can now expect employees to invest
in training and maybe they might even
start paying a better salary which means
we can get a better trained workforce a
better paid workforce and that might
mean some of those NEETs the 800,000
come off of benefits and go into work
this was a staggering shameful figure to
me in the sense that you know these
these these kids are just languishing
around you know and I think part of the
problem is you know every ladder has a
bottom rung and and to get anywhere in
life you have to start on that bottom
rung and I think the problem has been
that EU the the cheap labor which is
shameful in itself they occupied the
bottom rung of the ladder and I think I
think we have a culture thing to change
in the country that they do you know
even if your job you don't think is good
enough for you you have to do it anyway
but but I think the other point I was
making there is that you know large
employers have avoided investing in
techni
because of cheap labor productivity has
been bad because of the cheap labor and
and I and I think you know the British
workforce has kind of being forgotten
and all of this it's you know it's just
being cheap cheap cheap and we haven't
and you know even if we do one of the
problems of bringing skills here is that
we mustn't forget to invest in the
skills of here people here in Britain
that's what I was gonna say Ashley I
think that there are downsides to this
and one of them is that actually back to
the mistakes of Tony Blair his policy I
think of oversaturating graduations at
universities has led to too many people
with degrees that are unemployable from
a practical perspective while
de-emphasizing at the same time
vocational skills training courses
apprenticeships and if we start filling
those apprenticeships from people again
coming from abroad that may fit the
points criteria which I'd like to show
you here I have now the points criteria
from the Home Office website and it
tells us that the top three on this list
are compulsory that's offer of job by
approved sponsor that gives you 20
points job at appropriate skill level
gives you another 20 points speaks
English gives you 10 and then the rest
you see there are you know one or two of
them you could have as well that
increases your points but they're
optional not compulsory one on this is
at the bottom PhD in a stem subject and
it makes me wonder there for a long time
we haven't actually focused on
developing those skills domestically but
do you guys think this is a good idea
whoa so the point sister well I think
there are pros and cons to it and and I
think actually what's more important is
actually that we rather than repeat the
mistakes I've made in the past we
understand where the cons are like if
you look to Australia one of the
downsides to their to their system which
is a points-based system is they've got
these huge detention camps where people
sit in and entire families are in these
detention camps I wouldn't like to see
that I wouldn't like to see that in
Britain so we need to understand where
the weaknesses are and prepare for those
and plan ahead and it's funny Carol when
you when I first read you were gonna do
this topic I thought oh god she goes
again yeah but actually I have to say I
was quite surprised by where you then
took your subject matter in the center
I'm slightly conflicted I think on one
hand with these new
I think families like mine probably
would not have passed this point spate
system and I think that you and I get on
very well and I think you look quite
glad my mum and dad yeah I'm very glad
and I think that's a shame because
actually what this point based system
does is it says that there's only one
kind of person that has something to
contribute to Britain and we've heard of
the countless stories of people who come
without an education without anything
perhaps not even speaking you know
destroyed have gone on to do phenomenal
things in this country however I do
believe that one of the big issues we
have in this country is what we do with
our young people who come from parts of
the nation that have been forgotten
there's above all right have been on the
negative end of globalization who
haven't been trained and unskilled and I
think you're right in the sense that the
government needs to support business to
be able to bring those people into
there's a point that sadly sin makes
which I related to yours which is why I
just want to quickly bring in in chief
executive of the Joint Council for
welfare of immigrants that missing we've
got a system where tens of thousands of
children grow up in this country without
one of their parents where tens of
thousands of young people who were born
here brought up here are unable to
obtain citizenship what I'm worried
about is creating a two-tier system
where those that we're deeming is
low-skilled or low salary or cheap as
the Home Secretary calls them
essentially have fewer rights so I think
that I think it is important for us just
to make sure we avoid some of the
trappings of the Australian system in
particular when I heard him speak I
thought of the detention skill as regard
as the plaster and a brick yet I was
quite surprised to see there's seventy
percent of these they use citizens
either here at the moment what wouldn't
be here I think the question is going to
be about certain industries that
actually pay pretty close to the minimum
wage and particularly care industries
and there's a what happens how do you
get people to take those jobs in the
future well that's what we're talking
about incentives we've got to pay people
more this is the bottom line we can't
use the migrant labour low bar as
we have a pain let's not kid ourselves
if you would have paid more because
people in the care industry your oh well
it became in particular it's gonna cost
more to for for old people to live in
her so we get and this and most of that
is paid for by the state
what do you think that the I mean I'm
just asking what do you think the
percentages of people and from the EU
who work in our care homes what would
you put the percentage it's under ten
percent it's it's not a simple thing
exactly it's not as high as people think
and that's I think you know with the
transition pre we've got three point
five million people for they can plug
the gap until we transition and work out
how we can bring people in from the
Commonwealth I mean that's great results
we've we've neglected Australian Uzis
not Commonwealth partners and they think
they've got and the most somewhere of
the advantage is speaking English as
well so they're going to get through the
language test and why have we turned our
back on the Commonwealth since we've
been in the EU because we couldn't let
huge numbers from the contractor because
we were getting because we had to give
priority I'd like to pick up on that for
for a number of reasons one I think that
I think that that is a bit of a pipe
dream in the sense that right now we're
sort of glorifying the Commonwealth I
assure you when we've got tons of
immigrants coming in from the
Commonwealth we're gonna have the same
issues that we've had where there you go
so is gonna whether we've had with our
EU neighbors I think the issue when you
mention the Commonwealth is the
countries that you mentioned is there
yeah most of those countries have
thriving economies and I doubt very much
they're going to be lots of those people
that want to come over and do these not
for the jobs that we're talking about
here so I think you're gonna find that
the people from the Commonwealth that
we're gonna be coming to do the jobs
that we're talking about are not from
Australia Canada but I said it's will
you look at this policy the policy is
the poem system there's also you know
people are talking about the cap of 25
grand being too much there there is a
the system allows for situations where
we have job should shortages see like in
new
so it means you can come with less of a
weight for that and you could you can
earn more points if you're a nurse if
we're short of nurses if we're sort of
short of plasterers the system gives you
more points if we need them and that's
the whole point isn't it it's a it's an
immigration system that suits our needs
it's not finished but it's an
immigration system that actually
prevents us from perhaps getting the
type of innovation that we need because
somebody might not have all of that but
they've got something else to offer our
country and I think it's quite sad to
close the door on untapped potential